who likes comic books like superheroes
who likes superhero comic books from the
90s that's um yeah that's about what I
expected hey there i'm nathaniel wayne
from the council of geeks and while i
have always loved superheroes the only
period in which I was actually buying
superhero comic books was during the
much-maligned 1990s now those comic
books were sitting in my mother's attic
for about 15 years appreciating in value
not even a little bit I've now recovered
them and I'm going to be going through
these things issue by issue story by
story and try and answer in my own
little way the big question of we're 90s
comics really that bad chances are that
the answer is going to be yes but I
think that these comics deserve another
shot and they're going to get it on my
new podcast 90s comics retrial part of
the Council of geeks podcast you'll find
it on iTunes under council of geeks and
you can also go to 90s comics retrial
wordpress.com so check it out and take
this little trip down memory lane with
me I memory lane paved with what may be
some of the worst comic books ever
written we'll find out